let's start today talking a little bit
about vaccines
at this relatively later stage in the
pandemic for the united states there's
much still to be done globally but at
this
stage in the u.s where we could be
moving even more quickly
in crushing the virus 41 of republicans
still refuse to get themselves
vaccinated and sadly this number is down
only two percentage points from last
month you might remember last month we
had a new poll
which said 43 percent of republicans are
refusing the covet vaccine that has
declined but only two percentage points
to 41.
this is a new pbs npr
marist poll which finds that only four
percent of democrats
say i don't want the vaccine and yet 41
of republicans say they do not plan to
get vaccinated
and this truly could lead to more
eventual deaths for republicans than for
democrats which would at least to some
degree
shift the electoral balance what i mean
by that is
if mostly republicans are dying once we
get to the point at which everyone who
wants a vaccine has gotten a vaccine
it seems that would be bad for
republicans in their races
and maybe that and that alone at some
point or in some way
will influence republican elected
officials to encourage their voters to
get vaccinated but consider the
absurdity of this situation
the people who all along have been
saying there's really no serious
pandemic here
we don't have to do anything special we
don't have to go out of our way to
behave any differently open everything
right away uh get masks off those
very people who are the ones that never
wanted to wear masks
and don't want to get vaccinated are the
ones that say
open everything well wearing the mask
and get when that was the right thing
before we knew that vaccinated people
no longer need to wear masks per the cdc
getting vaccinated that would help us
open as quickly as possible and yet they
are refusing to do it
now overall 24 of the entire country
does not plan
to get vaccinated which is okay for herd
immunity once kids can get vaccinated
what i mean is if we do vaccinate 76
of all americans by all measures that's
enough to completely crush the curve
and get to a practical herd immunity
there will be sort of like a super
immunity in states where people
almost all want to get vaccinated places
like california
new york massachusetts where there's
more than 90 percent
interest in vaccination they will have
like a super immunity
on the other hand you will have cluster
outbursts
among uh unvaccinated people
in some parts of the country that are
not so big on getting themselves
vaccinated but the issue is no longer
vaccine supply
and that's maybe one of the most
infuriating aspects of this
we have the incredibly fortunate
situation
that many countries are dreaming of
which is vaccines for everyone there are
countries
desperate to get vaccines and start
vaccinating people
we have vaccines all adults are eligible
anyone 12 and over is eligible for the
pfizer vaccine in most states you can
now just walk in
no appointment just go and get a vaccine
and 41 of republicans just don't want it
and it's a very similar situation
with abortion i've used this analogy
before
they say we want zero abortions
great we know uh how to get in that
direction
give everybody contraception at no cost
out of pocket
teach everybody comprehensive sex
education this reduces the number of
unwanted pregnancies
and it reduces the demand for abortions
oh no we don't want to do that that's
crazy
that either violates our conscience or
it violates our religion or it violates
our morality or whatever the case
that's how you reduce abortions though
when they don't want to do it and it's
the exact same thing here hey we want
everything
back to normal cool just wear a mask
for now until the cdc says you don't
have to and as soon as you can get
yourself vaccinated get yourself
vaccinated
oh no not that that we're not going to
do it is fascinating that many of the
same people
who believed in hydroxychloroquine
absent any reason to believe in it as a
treatment for kovid
don't believe actual science like
vaccines the good
news is it's mostly the unvaccinated who
remain at risk now
it's not a hundred percent like that
because
there are some people who can't get
vaccinated because of specific medical
conditions
so you getting vaccinated protects them
there are people remember when we say
the vaccine is 92 to 95
effective that means five to eight
percent of people who get the vaccine
but because of a normal bell curve
distribution never develop
antibodies even though they did go and
get themselves vaccinated so
do the respectful thing do it for your
fellow homo sapiens go and get yourself
vaccinated
not necessarily or not only because
you're
assessing your personal risk but because
you're a member of society
you're a member of the human race and
maybe you would do something
that has somebody else in mind i know
that that's a crazy idea so
the bad news 41 of republicans still
don't want the vaccine
the good news if we are to focus on the
good news is
mostly the risk of people not
vaccinating is to themselves
although there is still risk to others
uh
and that number has gone down a little
bit 43
to 41 it's a little bit better we'll
continue to track vaccination numbers
and maybe have an
update uh maybe tomorrow maybe on
thursday
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15
off a high quality wrist watch is the
perfect way to
elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my vincero watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six
thousand five star reviews and they
stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy and
five-year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store
and free shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman